what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time while washer
is trying to get rich the rest of us
just trying to get our lunch money right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
polina evilova marinova pompliano
p-i-m-p
pimp in the house what's up girl what's
up
boy oh she got the devil wears prada
outfit on today ready to savage me
who's are you good are you good who's
our sponsor today
are you good oh i think planet is
annoyed with me it's fine i was bugging
the hell out of her before we got
started but that's okay
because it's friday uh sponsor today is
block five block five
has three products you can buy and sell
crypto you can take
crypto and deposit it in a block fi
account and take out a us dollar loan
against it so you don't have to sell
your crypto but you can still get us
dollar liquidity
and lastly they've got a product that is
my favorite i'm an investor in the
business
and a user of this product which is the
interest bearing account
if you put your money into a bank
account you get like
0.05 or 0.03 interest
if you put this into an interest bearing
account at block five they turn it into
a stable coin or you can deposit crypto
and earn up to eight point six percent
apy
8.6 apy there's risk do your own
research but
i like it i like getting my check every
monday
first monday of the month go to
blockfly.com
lunchmoneyblockfy.com
lunch money do it what's up are you done
are you done
fortnight don't wait by the way don't
don't think that we don't realize these
little uh
you got these little frilly things going
on here i like them
yeah oh let's go what's up what's up
fortnite developer
epic games suing apple and google after
both pulled
epics hit game fortnite from their app
stores
over direct payment disputes
what do you think about this i think
that
apple and google are going to do
whatever they want but that doesn't mean
that fortnight can't
come at them and sue them epic games
just did a corporate surprise attack
that's what just happened here
so for context apple requires
any app that's in their app store to
give 30 of digital purchases to apple
sounds reasonable right until you
realize that it one is a monopoly so
there's no free competition
two is you realize that they don't
evenly apply these rules to everyone
and then three is that they have become
more emboldened over time to the point
where now they basically believe
any commerce that happens on an iphone
that's not on the internet
should be 30 to apple but is this new
did they
just start doing that yes or they just
started
actually enforcing the rules on
fortnight no so
long story short is there's companies
like audible and netflix that the work
around for this was
audible for example used to tell you you
can't buy anything
in the app you have to go to the web you
have to put your credit card in you can
buy the
audiobooks on the web and then they'll
download on the mobile app and you can
listen to them on the mobile app but the
purchases happened
off the mobile app so that apple didn't
get a cut netflix same thing you
couldn't buy a netflix membership in
app you had to go to the web sign up
there and then you could use the mobile
app
now what we're getting is people are uh
started to do that so like base camps
hey uh email and apple said no you're
not allowed to do that anymore
and basecamp's like oh wait a second
netflix is still doing it right or
another example is
amazon launched their prime amazon prime
video
the mobile app for that and apple
allowed them to use their own credit
card
payment processor inside the app right
so the rules are not equally applied
even though apple continues to say that
they are
it's very obvious there's very distinct
examples where it's not and so what epic
basically did is
they said when you go to buy a digital
good inside of
fortnite they hit you with a pop-up and
the pop-up presented two opportunities
you can buy this through apple and pay
the full price
or if you buy it through epic right so
you circumvent
apple they'll give you a 20 discount and
so
because epic was saving 30 on every
purchase
basically they were passing 20 of that
on to the customer
so of course the customers all started
buying the digital goods through
epic rather than apple because they got
20 discount apple saw this
kicked them off but it became very
apparent very quickly
epic was this is was a surprise attack
so when apple kicked them off
they immediately served apple with a
lawsuit so the lawsuit was obviously
pre-written
and then they set up a commercial and
they're running a commercial inside the
fortnite game right now
that is a uh mocking of apple's famous
1984 commercial
and what they're basically saying is
like we stood up to apple and apple's
trying to prevent
billions of people from playing our game
like free fortnight
and like together we can stand up to the
man and
in the lawsuit it says apple is bigger
more powerful more entrenched and more
pernicious than monopolies of yesteryear
apple's size and reach far exceeds that
of any technology monopolist in history
isn't that so funny because i literally
remember being in
middle school and my friend's dad was
some sort of graphic designer he had
they had an apple in their home
and i was like wow what is that and it's
like you know they're trying to stand up
to the man and they're small and
whatever and it's just like
every disrupter becomes the man if
they're successful
one at one point bill gates was the
disruptor he was the guy in the garage
steve jobs was the guy in the garage
they were trying to take down
the the incumbents take down the uh
monopolies of their years
but if you are successful you end up
becoming the monopoly
right and that's what we're watching so
i actually think that apple is going to
have to cave on this regulations aren't
going to allow him to do it
uh epic games shout out to you guys epic
games by the way is based in kerry north
carolina where i grew up
[Music]
you always knew where their office was
because uh in the shopping center where
they had their office
uh they had a bunch of ferraris and
lamborghinis did you ever play fortnite
uh no i've actually never played
fortnite i'm not really into uh those
types of video games
now madden oh y'all can come get some of
that guys
i've never lost a madden game in my life
ask my brothers
one time we went to this uh like
arcade or sports bar or something i
don't know what it just had those games
and we played mario kart remember
and there were four screens so we played
with two other people
and the entire game i played and then
and then i realized that i actually lost
because i was looking
at the wrong uh square on the screen i
thought somebody else was me and i
thought i was playing so well
but in reality it looks like i wasn't so
long story short it's plena just like
she's never beat me in chess has never
beat me in a video game not true
what's up with fanatics we're playing
chess tonight sports retailer fanatics
close a 350 million dollar investment
round
a sign of investor confidence in the
combination of online shopping and
official sports
merchandise i don't okay hold on so with
the funding round closing fanatics is
now valued at roughly 6.2
billion after raising about 1.5 billion
since
2011. so i just don't understand i
thought
sports works dead no so the fanatics
business model basically is it's an
online
shopping store right is it like merch
yeah it's basically merch but the key is
that they have gotten licenses
from every major sports in america so
they've gone to the nfl the nba mlb et
cetera and so they can sell
all the jerseys all of the licensed con
like materials and
and merchandise i did not know my
brother actually wrote about this this
morning if you go to
read huddle up dot com he writes
something
uh he writes a email every single day at
read huddle up dot com
about the business and money behind
sports and so i was reading it this
morning and
michael rubin had a company called gsi
commerce michael rubin is the uh the ceo
of fanatics
and gsi commerce bought the company
fanatics
back in um i think it was like 2009 or
2011 whenever it was
uh for about 277 million dollars in cash
in stock
michael turned around and sold gsi to
ebay for about 2.4 billion dollars right
so he had a holding company he bought
fanatics
then he sold his holding company to ebay
ebay said look we just want the payment
technology you have so
we're going to sell you back all of the
underlying subsidiaries so
rue lala fanatics a couple of others
and since then michael rubin has
basically raised the 1.5
billion which is now 1.8 billion he's
built
uh that fanatics business into a six
plus billion dollar company
and so it's one of these stories where
the entrepreneur understood a market
was able to build a business sell it
bought back a piece of it now grew that
to be even bigger than the original sale
and michael rubin is uh a billionaire at
this point
and uh he owns the uh philadelphia 76ers
it's pretty crazy that he started the
business in 1995.
yeah well i think that the fanatics
business started in 1995
michael rubin bought it around 2010
but he didn't actually found fanatics he
bought it from two brothers
and then he scaled it basically so shout
out fnatic shout out michael rubin meek
mill what up
yup plane didn't even know what i just
said all right me come on what up
yeah meek mill meek mill okay ready he's
boys with reuben
go ahead ruben's the one who did that
website during cove
all in chat all in challenge yep all
right so this is kind of
strange and interesting yale
university's undergraduate admissions
process
illegally discriminates against white
and asian students the department of
justice said thursday
a two-year investigation into the ivy
league school found that race is the
determinative factor
in hundreds of admissions decisions each
year which is a violation of title
six uh eleven no
vs five oh my god i was like it's vegas
of the civil rights act of 1964 the doj
said can i go on my hot take is this
going to be a rant of the day
yeah you want to hear it listen i
the craziest part to me is people try to
solve racism with more racism
if you use race to make a decision it is
racism it doesn't matter if you're
doing that for white people black people
purple people green people asian people
whatever it doesn't matter if you make
decisions based on race it is racism
and so that is what the doj is coming
think about this yale
just got found to be guilty of
essentially racism they call what is the
terminology they use
they call it something uh go all the way
top i didn't see
uh illegal discrimination is what they
call it which aka is racism so it's
illegal discrimination
on race racism yale just got accused of
and uh found to be racist against white
people
think about that how crazy is that so
right it's because
we've gotten into a culture and a world
where we think that
to solve one problem we can basically
leverage the same thing against other
people
but if you want to solve the problem
with
quotas and all this stuff all you're
doing is you're just shifting the racism
somewhere else
so how do you solve it so this is the
complex part right there has to be a
solution
but what you end up having to do is you
have to get away from
building a system right the first system
that was built was highly racist towards
african americans and other people right
so there's a bunch of groups that there
was racism going on
the numbers are like so compelling that
racism existed in system
one then people realized that problem
and they said let's build a second
system
but the problem is that they baked in
racism in the second system as well just
they shifted it against somebody else
and then they were like oh well nobody
can be racist against asians for example
within the the department of justice
this isn't some like crazy website or
blog
the department of justice had a two-year
probe
that found this to be true and so what
you have to do is you have to back up
and you have to realize wait a second
why are we making college admission
decisions based on race
that's what's going on here yeah yeah
and so what you have to do is you have
to move to a system
that one recognizes the unconscious bias
right there's absolutely bias
right so you have to build into the
system the nfl for example
one of the things that the nfl did that
i thought was really interesting is they
said every single time
that a uh head coaching job becomes
available
you they attack the interview process so
they say you have to and i forget the
exact details i think it's either one
minority or multiple minority i think
espn did something similar in their
hiring process so it says look we're
still going to hire the best person for
the job
but to ensure that there is a fair
opportunity right you have to use race
as the interview process so the decision
isn't based on race but the actual
process making sure that uh you're
getting it diverse
exactly audience it's not just race it's
also ethnicity
and gender and all that just having a
diverse group of people
all have an equal shot at that job uh i
thought this wasn't actually an
interesting quote so
eric dryband the assistant attorney
general for the department civil rights
division
said in the press release there is no
such thing as a nice form of race
discrimination
unlawfully dividing americans into
racial and ethnic blocks fosters
stereotypes bitterness and division
it is past time for american
institutions to recognize that all
people should be treated
with decency and respect and without
unlawful regard for the color of their
skin
yeah and and by the way here's the crazy
part is
the quote-unquote nice form of race
discrimination right
is one true that's basically what
people's defense of this is
but the second piece is that the the
folks that i know
right so i'm not gonna name any names
but i know a number of
uh let's take asian or african american
people who went to ivy league schools
and when you talk to them they're
actually incredibly
uh kind of honest about it right so i
know a bunch of guys who played football
for example
and they're like hey dude if i couldn't
run fast i wasn't getting in that school
right i believe that about where i went
to school if i couldn't run fast i
wasn't getting into the school
if they look at it and they say oh and
by the way my race helped me
like they they're they're cognizant of
it they don't agree with it but they're
cognizant of it and so what you end up
doing is when you have a system
you can't blame the people of course the
people are going to just you tell me the
rules of the system
if i have an advantage to get the thing
that i want of course they're going to
leverage it
and so ultimately just goes back on the
school the school has to do a good job
and they have to spend the time money
and energy if you want more diversity on
your campus
you have to go find the diverse students
you can't
make this decision but there's plenty of
people of all races
that meet the qualifications to get into
yale or any other school go find them
and
here's the thing like i encountered
going to the university of georgia which
is predominantly white
when i was in those classes you could
look at me and you could think i'm white
but at the same time i bring a sense of
diversity that
some of those kids had never known like
i didn't speak english until i was nine
my parents are immigrants like i have a
different perspective
even though the color of my skin may put
me in a certain category
look the whole thing is stupid when you
break down the fact that you never know
somebody's story
right right right right planet and i
have a very diverse group of friends to
the point where literally
uh two of our favorite people in the
world are people who came to the united
states from pakistan they literally
lived in a
village with no internet seven years ago
it's crazy and they're now here and they
run a business that's worth tens of
millions of dollars right
uh go buy adam's shoes but
the whole idea is like they went from no
internet to today being highly
successful and when you meet them you
don't know where they born in the united
states were they born somewhere else
what languages they spoke growing up
like you know all that stuff
be curious well i just think it's all
about just being curious
and i think that the reason we have such
a diverse group of friends is because
we genuinely like interesting people
with interesting stories
yeah my whole belief in life is just
winners win that's it
if you're a winner you'll win don't
worry okay barstool sports dave portnoy
buys bitcoin after
tyler and cameron winklevoss went to his
office
and pitched him on it uh they didn't go
to his office they went to his hampton
home so
i obviously didn't watch this but you
did dave porter's gonna be a billionaire
look this is great i mean absolutely
comical uh
he's calling himself the baron of
bitcoin
look portnoy gets uh marketing and
social media better than most people
uh i think that there's this whole world
of uh crypto that's super excited about
uh him coming in uh cameron and tyler i
think did a great job
uh in terms of just getting him in um to
to a bitcoin
as i continue to say to people uh once
you buy an asset i don't care if it's
real estate stocks bitcoin gold whatever
it is
you start paying attention right you got
skin in the game and so uh
portnoy of course can't do anything uh
slowly so i think he bought
um a couple hundred thousand dollars
worth of bitcoin yesterday uh and so now
he's already tweeting about it i saw him
tweeting memes and all kinds of crazy
stuff uh you know
i've got deep conviction there but uh
we'll see how it plays out
so but you were he was watching the
video he was like cracking up
i mean it's hysterical because it's just
it was the classic example of like once
you've gone down this rabbit hole and
you understand bitcoin you understand
that gold's not scarce you understand
the federal reserve system like you
understand provable scarcity
like it to people who do it every day
we're just like duh
when you look at though uh people who
have no clue like
porno was like wait what there's gold on
asteroids and elon musk is gonna mine
them
right and he's literally looking at like
are you guys joking and they're like no
we're dead serious
and so it's just once you get down the
rabbit hole like your mind gets blown
yeah yeah and then people don't buy more
bitcoin all right what's up
okay so the owner of
office shared office provider wework
told employees on thursday that it has
slashed its cash burn rate almost in
half from the end of last year and
obtained a 1.1 billion commitment
in new funding from majority owner
softbank what is softbank doing i
thought they kind of backed out
i actually think that softbank is uh
going to
probably not make a lot of money here
but wework's gonna feel like i have to
sneeze oh no
okay wework's gonna get into a uh a
great financial position
why it's just the thing where like they
have so much revenue
um and it was all expenses and when you
slash the expenses i think they'll still
keep high
level of revenue and so eventually
they'll get to some level of
profitability like revenue in the
quarter reached 882 million dollars
so company does almost four billion
dollars in annual revenue
uh and it was up nine percent from a
year earlier right so
think about that like they've already
done basically two billion dollars in
revenue and q1q2 this year
and so i think that um wow do you think
there will be a wework
comeback well i think it'll just turn
into a profitable business right
and uh they've got a bunch of debt and
they got to kind of figure some stuff
out but but i do think that actually
this business
uh could be super profitable um and i
also think that they had to burn
the cash they burnt to get to the
position they got yeah it was just they
didn't clean it up before they tried to
go public they basically tried to go
public with like
you know the trash can on fire yeah if
they had simply put the fire out and
said hey look we're not burning as much
cash anymore we're gonna get rid of all
kind of the crazy
you know uh nefari not nefarious but
like incestual type stuff
uh i actually think that this would have
been a huge success um
jeff lewis from bedrock told me once he
goes the difference between wework being
super successful
and ending up the way that they did was
a matter of like a week
like if they'd gotten out a week earlier
well it would be in public markets and
this wouldn't have blown up
life catches you like that true uh if we
had
if we had planned our wedding exactly uh
a month before
well if you had listened to me and we
got married when i said that we should
have been
um guys i have been looking for
a dining room table and now like all of
the ads are dining room too nobody cares
about your
uh ad preferences it's crazy michigan
plans to redesign a stretch of road for
self-driving cars
can you read the internet i didn't okay
so michigan
is teaming up with tech and auto
companies to attempt to retrofit a
roughly 40-mile stretch of two roads
outside detroit exclusively for
self-driving vehicles
i actually i wonder i've always wondered
why they don't just you know how
one lane is always usually for those
trucks
why don't they just automate or like
make that self-driving and only have
that lane for them
well so there's a couple of things here
i'm guessing when they say retrofit what
they're gonna basically do is gonna put
a lot of sensors and cameras and all
that kind of stuff on this
stretch of road that makes the cars
infinitely more
yeah yeah sensors and cameras oh it's
like i
understand how self-driving physical
barriers may be added as well which make
it easier for the vehicles to drive
safely yeah
because think about it right the way
that a self-driving car does is either
they use cameras or they use like a
sonar type
uh thing and so one of the big
issues is on a highway if it can just
see the lines on the road it just
follows it and then it basically
just reads the car in front of it and
make sure it doesn't slam into it
like that's all pretty simple from a
computer science perspective
when you add other cars on the road you
mean computer vision perspective
well when also you had other cars on the
road and people are doing crazy stuff
right it's like when i was a kid my
daddy's just telling me all the time
he's like i'm not worried about you
doing something i'm worried about the
other people on the road now little did
i know he actually was worried about me
too
you're the other people on the road the
best thing is when you learn to drive
what
uh remember when you went driving for
the driving test my favorite moment i've
talked to my brothers about this and
it's theirs as well
is when you go to go on the highway and
you're on the on-ramp and the person's
like faster
faster faster they did not need to tell
me to go fast you're going like you know
you're first like a 20
30 40 50 60 and then they're just like
faster
and i remember when the woman said it to
me i just punched the gas and we went
from like
60 to like 85. she like slowed down sled
slow down
i uh yeah what nothing did you pass the
first time
of course oh okay i'm an excellent
driver guys did you have to do the uh
parallel parking yeah you did it yeah it
was like way too big i was like that's
so easy i thought it was gonna be super
tight they put the cones like a mile
away
also um on my test the guy who was next
to me this was like i took it like seven
in the morning
and he wouldn't like he'd be like go
right
and i'd be like excuse me and he's like
i can't repeat it and i was like
i didn't hear you it's not that i don't
know how to go right it's that i didn't
hear what you said so i just like
went and then and then when i finished
and i passed he was like uh by the way
you need to uh
follow directions better it's like what
the hell is that i couldn't hear you
speak up and enunciate
my man if you're watching this enunciate
she ain't learned to follow directions
any better now don't worry
all right so do we like this idea what i
do i i do but i just
don't understand why they haven't done
it yet like our roomba can recognize a
chair from a mile away and doesn't slam
into it
very gently to be clear okay so uh the
roomba is actually stupid
got it uh every by the way every single
uh road at some point in the future is
going to be armed for this
okay i have a great joke for today guys
are you ready yeah what's up devil wears
prada what do you call a dinosaur with
an extensive vocabulary
a rhaptosaurus no i was gonna say you
um i do have great command of the
american language
a thesaurus
i think that was funny yes
i did not uh by the way i just want to
call out the fact that uh
i actually like this shirt that you're
wearing today nobody cares no but you
have medieval sleeves
no my sleeves are perfect i just like
them that's all that's all i wanted to
say
all right guys that's it for lunch money
this week we appreciate it as you can
see
we have tried to upgrade a little bit we
got this nice camera we got these
microphones
we're going to have a background so yeah
guys when the background comes
you guys ain't going to bother you a lot
of you voted for the bitcoin thing i i
did see
uh and i did you got destroyed in the
vote i did look up the history of
the picture that i like in it is not
great what's the problem uh
what is it a lot of problems okay um
it's controversial basically he grabbed
a random woman on the street and kissed
her
as he was on the way to visit his
girlfriend or whatever but anyway he was
just so happy but
she didn't want to get kissed like who
the hell is this guy oh he was so happy
that he he he just grabbed this nurse
and kissed her or whatever
and some somebody from life magazine
captured the photo
then his other girl found out because it
was on the cover of everything
i don't know i don't think that's i
think the controversy is more the woman
did not want to be kissed by this random
dude
so anyway okay we'll put up your bitcoin
so you had a picture of molestation
no i think that's the definition no okay
all right all right guys that's it for
today well while she's trying to get
richer so just trying to get her lunch
money right
bang bang see you tomorrow or monday i
guess
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends